and then like I'll date another Asian
girl or Chinese girl right and then like
they'll be like yeah they're like we sh
they're they they think that we
shouldn't get married I'm like why it's
because they know that Japanese guys
they get drunk and they always cheat on
their wives all the time and I'm like
where does this come from my dad doesn't
even drink alcohol but he does cheat on
my mom
[Music]
so um here we are off the Record again
we found ourselves off the Record
uh went back when you guys were
teenagers yeah
what are some negative stereotypes we
heard about each other's ethnicities
Steve go okay easy wait wait how long do
I have ah I only have 20 minutes 20
minutes isn't enough go around the room
Jesus like real ones that you actually
heard that were said that were said
seriously okay okay one of the more
[__] up ones that I heard is that you
guys are really smart
Taiwanese right I heard that Taiwanese
people are extremely extremely cheap
is that true oh yeah it's actually a
true one most of the Chinese people I
know are [__] stingy what was the
example like Wizards well I had I had a
lot of Cantonese friends and for some
reason I don't know if there's a rivalry
or whatever but they would always roast
Taiwanese people and I wasn't I never
met a Taiwanese person and then they
would just always talk [__] about how
Taiwanese people are so cheap all the
time and then I was like it just it just
sounds funny like they just have a lot
of jokes but I I don't know
and I think I did have time with these
friends but I didn't know that they were
telling these because I didn't ask oh
later on in life I'm like oh okay but
that was something I kept hearing over
and over
I was here the Japanese people are
perverts
seriously seriously and that grew up and
I was like oh [__] they are who told you
that I don't know just [__] like
random like older like kids on the field
or whatever you know what I mean and
they would just be like this [__]
Japanese kids stuff like you're pervert
and I would always be like what why is
he a pervert he's Japanese and he's like
I didn't get it you know what I mean you
don't get it until you start [__]
really watching [__] like porno that's
funny the one that I got was Japanese
Americans don't speak Japanese
but that's true yeah they're like they
don't speak it some of them are like
four gens deep I was talking to my uh my
sisters me and my sister were talking
about this and we're telling my wife
about how my grandpa back in the day he
would ask my sisters he's an old Chinese
dude and he like served in the military
and he was like
you guys got any friends that are
Japanese and my sisters were like no he
goes good
he didn't want any of uh my sisters to
hang out with it in Japanese yo it's
hardcore though he's from that
generation
my Korean uh friend was having a
sleepover and I was um we were all
playing but I couldn't stay they were
allowed to stay and I had to go home
whoa yeah cause I was Japanese and then
their grandma didn't like that or
whatever and then because he was like
sorry you can't stay and I was like why
because oh uh my grandma doesn't like
that you're Japanese so I was like okay
that's [__] weird and I didn't get it
yeah and I had it and I was like telling
my mom I was crying and [__] I was like
they don't like me because I'm Japanese
and they're like oh well
don't worry we'll kill them later
time letting go or some [__] she told me
something as a kid can you imagine
playing a little kid it's so incredible
yeah yeah yeah he runs deep Bro Japanese
American Kids
great you know like I was just so petty
honestly it takes Petty to a level that
I didn't even think was possible and I
respected about it too and you're Petty
WAP I'm very Petty but on the flip side
there were a lot of like not like Korean
Chinese uh Vietnamese grandmas that
spoke Japanese because of the
colonization right they they would they
were trying to make them speak Japanese
so they remember when they were kids
going to those those programs so then
they when they knew that I was a
Japanese they would speak to me they
would sing songs to me and [__] and I
thought that was cool until later I grew
up and I'm like oh they were in those at
re-education camps
that's why they know Japanese but they
never passed that hate on to me at all I
didn't know because I was a kid that's
the only time that one Korean grandma
was upset about that wow
good teachers in those camps good
teachers most of my racism was learned
from my parents I think what did your
parents say about Filipinos
um they told they would tell me
nothing actually does nothing bad about
Filipinos
but yeah there's nothing bad about
Filipinos wow yeah it was mainly about
like my dad was like when I first got
with Geo he was like you better watch
out she's she's gonna like right after
kids it's like it's in the DNA it's
gonna be fat as [__] blowing up she's
gonna balloon up it's gonna be like 300
pounds he's like just just be careful
that's guard bar so he started the gym
with her
preventative preventative he might want
to work out a little bit of that face
Geo he said that yeah yeah
his dad your father in law
dude I didn't I didn't even know what a
Vietnamese was until High School what
did I say what a Vietnamese was like who
says I had Vietnamese friends but like
it just didn't to me I thought they were
all just Chinese we all heard that like
because I had mostly like friends that
were Filipino Korean Japanese Chinese
not really a lot of Vietnamese but then
once I reached high school we started
running into them places everybody would
always tell us to watch out for them oh
oh that's true because they're crazy
they said Vietnamese guys have the
craziest temper like you might lose your
temper but you won't go as far as a
Vietnamese guy will you guys were raised
for a hell of racism dude yeah yeah
so much racism and then they were like
they're because then a lot of fights
would happen and then people would just
assume oh it's just yeah guys mom always
told me like if you're around white
people you better act right because
they're gonna Sue yourself yeah dude
she's like you better not [__] around
that's why they know the law and they
will sue your ass
we wouldn't really have white kids come
over because we were scared their
families would sue us that's so funny
yeah we were all my whole family was
scary my mom told me never get no fight
because she doesn't want to get sued but
other white people my other white people
oh no I was raised you know that's funny
but I was raised around everybody so
like you know they just like don't
[__] fight anybody we'll get sued wow
they're scared shitless also some of the
stereotypes
it's interesting like how it's formed
because uh where I grew up my first
house I could really remember my next
door neighbor was a Filipino family
but they were like a Filipino cholo
family so I always thought Filipinos
were only cholos because they were they
were like you know like the shorts down
again white socks and then there was the
one they were like teach me how to like
uh tag with like sidewalk chalk on the
ground so it would like [__] tag up
the whole the whole sidewalk and [__]
and then so like um I thought all
Filipinos were cholos until I realized
no that's wrong they're actually all
break dancers
was a new one because uh growing up in
Cerritos all the Vietnamese I knew were
like second or third generation and I
didn't know that they had like a refugee
type culture until I came here and I was
like holy [__] A lot of these guys just
came here like [__] last week and
they don't give a [__]
hey you know what I learned about you
know what I heard about Filipinos when I
was in high school this most [__] up
thing I heard like hey dude Filipino
dudes all leave their wives oh [__] oh I
heard about the Korean dudes all beat
their wives and I heard that too oh [__]
beat and leave oh you know what I've
heard a lot of racism from girls that
I've dated from their parents like she
would be like yeah my mom thinks that
you're gonna beat my ass because you're
Japanese oh [__]
Asian girl or Chinese girl right and
then like they'll be like yeah they're
like we sh they're they they think that
we shouldn't get married I'm like why
it's because they know that Japanese
guys they get drunk and they always
cheat on their wives all the time and
I'm like
cheat on my mom but you know
you know you know what's crazy is I have
heard that stereotype too about
Filipinos but I couldn't identify with
it because when you're Filipino
Christian nobody gets divorced but then
once I started meeting more Filipinos
that were not Christian a lot of them
had broken families or dads that would
peace out it was always dads it's not
just husbands it's it's like Filipino
men were like two they're like
casanovaish or like player-ish or
athletes huh even when they're older or
they're like salsa teachers you got like
four or five lives it's like Spanish
culture bro damn man and I didn't know
that I honestly just think white people
aren't dishonest
because like you guys like you guys are
raised in this it's like all these
Japanese people all these Filipino all
these Vietnamese people and like when
I'm growing up none of that it's like
nobody wants to admit it maybe I don't
[__] know no it's because you got to
go back to Europe where people are like
the Dutch the Irish the sky oh right you
know what I mean but like over here it's
just white right yeah like Irish people
they get they get drunk and they fight
or whatever the Italians are like a
French or romantic yeah but over here
Italians Irish or Germans they're all
just white yeah yeah there's also a
strange thing where like I think it's
like when you're first gen American and
your your family's from Asia they're
gonna tell you things not in the reason
that you should hate them but it's for
you to watch out because the odds are
against you but that is racist
it is racist it's like they're all like
this so watch out yeah it's racist and
it's racist but it comes from like pure
uneducated stupidity yeah like my
grandma right like I think it was the
first year she was in in the states she
didn't know anything about slavery she
should know anything about that we just
lived in a black neighborhood she
thought there's so many Africans that
came here she doesn't know yeah she's
like we're gonna Africa neighborhood and
that's what she would tell all her
friends like oh yeah we live in kind of
like a little Africa little Nairobi
because she thought that America was
literally just a big Melting Pot where
there's Chinatown there's Little Tokyo
there's all that right so she's like
yeah there's so many like she thought
they're just all first-gen immigrants
yeah wow damn my parents would always be
like
we're Chinese right he goes both my mom
and my dad would tell me separately like
don't work for Chinese people they're
cheap just don't work for them dude I've
heard that from my Chinese friends yeah
like they would just tell me that um
completely true but you know I'm sure
there's there's you know exceptions to
the rule and then my mom would always
say stuff to me like and we've we've
actually talked about this before but
like my mom used to always be like
like you need to wear a sweater like
you're gonna get cold you're not like
those white or black kids you're gonna
get they're really strong yeah yeah like
they would they would say things like
that to me growing up in a weird way
where I would just like have this weird
complex because I'm not a [__] yeah
dude and now you would think like and
then in my dad's eyes he'd be like yeah
like dude those black guys on the court
like they're just you can't stop them
like that's how he would talk he would
talk about how like black dudes are just
really good at basketball and like
really hard to guard like you would just
say that like that that's that was his
thing positive racism I'm here all day
for him like I'm down oh dude these guys
are so quick like you just can't stop
them like you you try to move your feet
you can't you can't get in front of them
because you like love basketball like
that was his lens
when I watched like any Asian Tick Tock
of a guy who's like you know what I'm
Asian I'm not a doctor it's like oh my
god dude shut up
you're right yeah people assume you're
smart and you're educated that's like a
bad stereotype holy [__] how will you
ever make it the only time that that
that's like used wrong is when someone's
trying to discredit you working hard at
something and they're like you didn't
even have to [__] try your Asian
you're like all right well that's true
yeah that's how you gotta do it if you
want to compare it to the Discrimination
Olympics we don't have it as bad as some
other groups like it's like wow the [__]
they're [__] accused of it's like
well [__] what about gypsies that are
like oh you're coming from a culture
that just steals all day and cheats
people can't say gypsies yes you can't
even say that anymore what are they what
are they like Travelers or something I
think they have
it's like imagine if you have the stain
of like it's like it's like Asian kids
are crying about oh you have a stain of
being a doctorate intelligent imagine if
you [__] born and people think you're
from a culture of theft and crime and
like nothing swag and you have to wake
up every day going like everyone thinks
like the Italian heal someone yeah steal
some [__] do some crime not be you know
it's like
you're untrustworthy like all that [__]
like what the [__] dude you know what I
love it's like so we just came out of
the Christmas season and [__] like that
or the holidays
um and you know as I'm at Trader Joe's
or anywhere and it's like people like
Merry Christmas I'm like oh okay Merry
Christmas or whatever or happy Holidays
happy holidays you can say that to any
Chinese person and there you can say
Happy New Year to any Chinese person
right and they're just like happy New
Year even but they're not like my New
Years and [__] a month
I never heard that in my life it
actually it's in February that's not my
[__] New Year actually you've never
heard that um
that's true yeah you wouldn't actually
it's a February and that's it it's been
celebrated that way for thousands of
years exactly they have their own New
Year people say happy new year they just
happy New Year back and everyone flips
the [__] out of my life out yeah
everyone's like I don't say Merry
Christmas they won't say happy Saint
Patty's Day back to you though I bet you
watch okay I'll try they probably don't
even know what you said it's a good
toast
anybody else uh racist
I just mean you know it's just like what
other times I remember actually hearing
my uh well yeah like my family they'd be
like yeah Filipino food's not that good
but they never [__] had it like they
they would or they had like a bad batch
yeah they're just talking about their
[__] ass dude do you guys remember
this
um you know back in the day right when
when things went viral it was like email
chains or some [__] so like there'll be
you don't email this you have a bad luck
for 12 years no yeah like that and then
they would forward it yeah there was one
about like which Asians hate each like
which Asians hate which Asian right
they'll be like oh yeah Koreans hate
Japanese and then the Vietnamese hate
this and then all this stuff and then it
goes but Chinese they hate Chinese and
that was like the punch line because
that's that's kind of like The
Stereotype of like everyone has Rivals
but the Chinese no one hates the Chinese
more than the Chinese hate the Chinese
that's true we're good at that bro for
real because and it's the funniest
stereotype because like I'll just be
eating dinner like at my Chinese
friend's house or like we're at a
restaurant or whatever and out of
nowhere they just start talking [__]
about Chinese people and that's the
funniest [__] to me because I'm just
sitting here giggling and then they're
like [__] why Chinese people so ugly man
and I'm all like you're Chinese
like what the [__] and where does this
come from and then one time I was eating
hot paw my friend's dad right and he's
all like ah I'm never gonna hire Chinese
don't [__] it you kind of reminded me of
that because you just said it but it was
like same [__] thing he's like don't
trust Chinese they're gonna [__]
steal your business and I'm all like but
you're Chinese that's like similar to
when um because of diversity is so large
like in China itself like if you go to
the Philippines you'll see a lot of
people that don't like the Scions or
don't like ilocanos like it's just
tribal but that makes sense because it's
not like it's like a different group
right that's like saying from you're
from Boston you don't like someone from
New York but you're not saying [__]
Americans
you're gonna be like
this continent's so swag man yeah by the
way most of us hate people from Boston
white people I don't know really oh yeah
in the [__] I think it's like in in
massels in the five six two maybe it's
just Lakewood and Cerritos for some
reason there was like an unspoken think
that Filipinos and cambodians didn't
like each other oh for sure that was a
thing nobody knew why really yeah what
do you think it was I don't know maybe
just like a beef between two very
popular people that just like everyone
wanted to copy them no it was it was
there you guys were fighting for the
title of a best jungle Asian yeah wow
you know who the the least self the
least self-loving Asian or Chinese
person that I know
are you Mexican nope I'm Chinese
you got that Steve confidence he just
put a whole country in the garbage
yeah I think about that randomly in my
head so many times nope I'm Chinese Soul
killer such a killer line dude growing
up it was confusing because my mom would
constantly talk [__] about Chinese
people and I'm like [__] you Chinese
like what are you talking about so us
growing up I'll be like like it made me
feel like Chinese was like the worst
race yeah yeah like I'm not as strong as
these people I'm not as smart as these
but I'm not as disciplined as these
people these guys got better jeans it
was like I was like why am I even living
dude
why are you so bummed out I never heard
anything bad about Chinese people but I
had it's only from Chinese people yeah I
had the looming feeling that Chinese was
just the default that's true Chinese was
default because also the rest of
non-asian people are always like what
kind of Chinese are you regardless like
as long as you had this you're Chinese
hey whoa that's gonna go viral whoa whoa
Also let's acknowledge the elephant in
the room guys little dicks are in all
right wait whoa whoa whoa whoa you're
gonna go like this though is it like
this yeah it's like that little dicks
are in I do have a really funny story
about one of my my teammates his name is
Kenny Huang he's a Taiwanese man okay
he's a he he fight he used to fight he's
an accountant right this [__]
after one of his fights he knocks some
dude out right as soon as he he finished
knocking the guy out he walked under the
cage and he just did this what
who's that guy but he just so [__]
funny he just walked around and was like
[__] funny though that's a great
celebration though yeah a Chinese man
doing Chinese eyes I wonder what the new
things are that like let's say parents
of teenagers that are second gen Asian
in Cali like I wonder what they tell
their kids about other races if they
even do well the new thing like even
when I was in college like uh like a new
stereotype that I would hear would be
like oh man Asians are really good
dancers thanks to you guys dude that's
probably the sickest [__] thing to
happen in my lifetime best thing that
ever happened to Asia that's [__]
crazy because I never grew up with that
because you guys
set that new stereotyping wow what's
happening in high school they're good
dancers or they're power lifters because
of this guy you know the show the show
blackish yeah they license the clip of
us to show in the pilot episode when the
main characters mad that Asians took
dance from black people
but it's like a positive thing it's like
he's like man that used to be the black
man's thing yeah yeah yeah yeah and I
was like dude I never thought of my
lifetime that could ever like the tide
could change that's pretty crazy because
I don't remember if I can let you know
Power Rangers like Mastodon I feel
[__] body rollers yeah dude he was
body rolling between kicks hip-hop keto
dude that's what he called it
the black Ranger
he was doing that why you got the hook
engine bay out there you're just
subconscious
ly delete that delete that
I think there are a lot of really cool
new stereotypes that's awesome oh I miss
racism though imagine that's what the
parents say they're like hey stay away
from that dance world there's Asians
there you don't want to be Chinese I
can't wait in 20 years we're gonna see
Asian kids going oh guess what guys and
I don't know how to dance
exactly with tears in there I know yeah
yeah yeah yeah not all of us are good
dancers
I'm a doctor and I can't dance it's so
good I'm so rebellious pause for Laughs
okay now you can continue
and my dick's huge
[Music]
foreign